大家好
歡迎收看我們今天的榮耀華爾街
今天我們要講三大重點
我們今天畫面不太一樣
等一下給他一個surprise
今天台灣股市大展
哇266點
什麼叫大展
因為很多人覺得跌1000點
可是為什麼0050下跌
等一下我一次跟大家講
第二個
中小型股大展40%
一堆股票展停板
我們的環球金
我們的國巨
讓他展就展
有救了嗎
可是韓國股市今天大跌
5%
怎麼會這樣
危機解除了嗎
今天講到這個東西
台股最近震很凶對不對
真的震很凶
為什麼震很凶
因為一會跌破4萬點
跌破了4萬點以後
哇 不好意思
哲哲買了1億0050
馬上上漲了1000點
上漲了3000點
每個人說1億0050賺1000萬
哲哲好厲害啊
哇 那不好意思
那台股官股是今天震更凶啊
本來很多人說跌1000點
我說會上漲
很多人不相信哲哲
結果哇 真的今天又上漲了
可是除此以外
臉書卻都是我
可聽說有一個人比我更有名
哇韓國的吹傘
聽說他也跳一個什麼正胸
不是台鼓正很胸 正胸舞
我哪知道什麼叫做台鼓的正胸舞
來 music 上
是不是這叫正胸舞
大家你知道Live很累
壓力很大 我們剛才跳個快100次
我知道單分析師不好單啦好不好
我現在要下去
去問那個畫面解盤
我不知道節奏有沒有對
Key的節奏還可以嗎
沒問題
我們要切這畫面
我跟你講這個就不是AI了好不好
那個一般的畫面
可能人家YouTube撿很多次
我們是Live直播 讓人家騙不了人
我不知道大家喜不喜歡
這個單分析師 我剛才跳這個舞
我平常買股票不會發抖
跳舞
好緊張
這不是重點啦 我看今天又爆了
我們來看一下大家閃霧有什麼問題
來來來
那依依剛才OK嗎
OK 節奏有對嗎
有 好帥
真的嗎 笑死我了
活絲不錯
這只有在正版 沒有正嗎
真的嗎
有啦 你們不要這樣子
我啦 我
好啦 洗完喊一下口號
發生什麼事情
你們需要洗版的這樣子嗎
有沒有傳奇傳財經中心節目
對啦 可以再久一點
不行了 我這邊已經在抽金了 你知道
好啦好啦 你們畫面崩得很快
好不好
還是分析股票園
桌子沒了 桌子在這邊啦
桌子沒了 好不好
好啦 謝謝大家
今天整個爆掉了
今天直播人數
前面沒有看到人真的很可惜 是不是
整整沒有動
有麻魚
莉莉整得我沒有動嗎
我剛才是有吧
胸肌這樣好不好
有啦
不是 因為剛才節奏比較難好不好
我已經努力了好不好
身體很僵硬
妳不知道我從小到大沒在跳舞了
我還讀書打電動好不好
OK嗎 好啦 就這樣子啦
沒關係啦
妳們不喜歡我也沒辦法啦
這次已經努力了
來
反正做什麼事
我能夠經歷到最好
我們本來還叫莉莉要去買鼓耶
對不對 要把她打在鼓
是
結果買不到
到處都買不到
買不到 沒辦法
台灣學音樂的人真少
我們已經跑到台北市
全...
跑到新北市跑到蘆洲去了你知道嗎
結果還是沒有買不到
OK吧
好啦 那就是這樣子吧
那我們來看一下今天股票
那個你有沒有看到我們五大透的跌
台積電為什麼跌
今天台灣股市展台積電為什麼跌
因為我們有講這個溢價
對不對
我們有講來看一下
溢價什麼叫溢價
我說過
禮拜五是不是台積電暫停
但紅海沒暫停啊
五大全值股裡面
不是五大全值股
前五大全值股
紅海沒暫停
然後台達電也沒暫停
我說過你說國文英文數學
物理化學
五顆裡面
我說你平均100分
你四顆100分
一顆99分
你不能說你平均100分
你只要一顆沒有100分
就不能說平均100分
結果台灣股市昨天100分
暫停板所使
我講的是
那個台灣50
台灣50是個加權權重
所以代表是
這個是溢價多展了
所以今天把它拉回
我有沒有講在前面
有啊
你怎麼找到這樣的分析師
我是真的
預告在前面欸 真的
但分析師不好當欸 他預告未來
還要練身體
我們哪一天要唱歌
我們要唱歌 要跳舞
這把年紀了真的是
還有重訓 深蹲
真的
真的好不好
很辛苦喔
找到這樣多才多藝
重點是
我跳舞跳得好不好
不是重點
股票轉不轉比較厲害啊
各位好不好
是跟大家講
好不好
靠頭腦
你們是喜歡我的身體
還是喜歡我的財富
還是喜歡我的頭腦
我希望一起喜歡或喜歡我的頭腦
比較重要好不好
只是如果帥爐金城武
結果股票讓你賠錢
你也不想看喔
來來我們來看一下重播
預告在前面
來
我們還說
今天有機會翻紅
你看預告
來
我們看一下
熙熙之末
重來
3 2 1
90太高
我認為70%
明天跌的幅度會在-300點以內
甚至有機會翻紅
記起來我說的好不好
為什麼最重要的
亞馬遜的財報是自由現金流量是負的
你看有機會翻紅
我說亞馬遜財報自由現金量量是負的
代表這個 AI 泡沫假話題啊
為什麼之前 AI
為什麼之前
自由現金量量量為負的就跌
現在就漲了
是不是你看我預告前面禮拜六啊
你看禮拜六
在加班啊
我穿那麼正式啊來公司啊
今天正式來上班
我穿那麼不正式啊
我第一次穿那麼不正式好不好
以後不會啦好不好
且看且走好不好
看一次少一次
你比較喜歡這件衣服
還走這邊
好啦
好來來來先跟大家講
所以你看預告前面
直接講台灣股市漲
就像我講的五條的好不好
重點重點是
台灣股市漲
這時候預告在前面
這跟大家講
來看一下看一下
看一下
又有期待每天哽
你們不要拜託不要期待每天哽
這樣我壓力很大
好啦
來真的翻紅
外資空單88000口
你不要想那麼多
這個平常心好不好
謝謝大家
來
提審了謝謝
來來
我看每個人都看都不錯
來
身體加減喜歡
這樣真可口 謝謝大家
好
來我們看一下8000100真的
很重看直播
你們今天畫面泡得太快了
今天直播人數多少
怎麼都多
今天還有才5000 等於4800
那我們來慢慢看一下
扣子可不可以再解一顆嗎
就這樣就好了吧
不要再解一顆
如果有5就好了好不好
我們沒有那麼的心三色
星山社 到時候
小孩子不宜
做股票的人都18歲以上 沒關係
來 我們來看一下
你們看一下國巨也拉漲停了
國巨我們今天也公課前訊了
我們跟他講
國巨在低漲的時候
誰敢公開的買
而且我還第一時間跟你講
很多主動型ETF是砍在這一丁
訓掉了是不是
然後我還跟大家講
我從現在開始支持00981A
搖池基姆 我說我跟他站在同一陣線
而且我還說
你可以買00981A有沒有看到
有
我自己是買台灣50喔
我說你可以買00981A
但是我說買國具
買黃金可能賺更多
我們再講
有
你們看一下00981A
那一天是不是暫停對不對
禮拜五暫停嗎
今天還漲了3.75%
贏台灣50喔
欸你真的去哪邊找到這麼好的老師啊
欸我真的有時候公開送股票給你
我不在乎為什麼
因為我會員可以賺更多
欸我今天爸很開心喔
不是我剛才跳舞的節奏
有對欸
沒關係啦 那個我還是很怕一下
因為莉莉是音樂系
我待會剛才有沒有結得多麼對
有對啦 有啊
你知道我這邊已經抽筋了
我剛才錄影前
前10分鐘
還結做一直不對
看行情 然後頭要往後
還要很酷 你做麼
頭長練得很認真啦
我真的練得很認真 超過你們想像
我練到太認真
覺得我不像分析師
我還是看一下股票好了
不過只有練今天跟昨天晚上一天
兩天 我真的練很認真
你應該沒有想像我會練那麼認真吧
對啊
從來沒有看過
我本來就很認真
跳舞啦
跳舞從來沒有看過
因為我沒有底子啊
好不好
是跟大家講
做什麼事都要認真
那我要告訴大家
股票才是我
其實很多人天分是會跳舞唱歌
那是天分
我天分在做股票
你知道嗎
所以我做股票
就算隨便做都可以贏別人
更換我是很認真做股票的
所以很多人說
買1億的台灣50正很兇
可是我就敢買
我今天反而很開心
台灣50回答我反而很開心
為什麼
我根本不在乎我賺多少錢
沒關係反正我賺的錢
我還是要捐部分出去
我不知道什麼在不在乎
得知我命不得我信
我就說跌4萬點
跌破4萬點我就怎麼樣進產了
沒有跌破呢
就當作沒這回事嘛
你們賺錢啊
所以禮拜四我親切很差
你知道什麼
因為很多人說我台灣50有賺錢
可是股票跌停
啊 則是股票跌了
請問你們今天有什麼好講的
你們今天怎麼講一句話
折跳往下還好
你們不要跟專業無折比嘛
你們跟分析師比
可能我已經不錯了
我們要攻擊分析師
我是覺得各個分析師我都愛他們
好不好
大家都認真的
批評分析師也不會賺了錢
我還在重申一次
我們那天不是會小心頭套嗎
對
我不是要批評別的分析師
做控分析師
我們大家都好朋友好不好
除非一直針對哲哲
不然我真的欺負哲哲太兇
我才會回籍
那回籍就是很兇猛的
該提告提告
不然我講是同業啦
玩意我們不要太誇張
我都可以接受好不好
這跟大家講
其實批評分譯師到最後業績也不會好
這個都有例子了
好扯遠的來我們來看一下
我還是要講
國具今天是不是你看
所以00900A 搖瓷欽姆是不是買什麼
是不是買這個股票
是不是買國具
你看最近績效就很好啦
那買國具我們看一下重播
國具那時候跌停板
國具是之前天天沒有人要哦
斷手斷腳
用手接斷手用腳接斷腳
只有鍋子哦
我跟你講的
我最領好喔
我那天國巨的時候我說500
507元我說我這邊開始進產有沒有
我就講實在話
隔天我們還可以買到
有人如果運氣好可以買到400多塊你知道嗎
最低456
我在這邊跟你講你可以接最低耶
我在這邊講你可以接最低耶
我什麼時候叫你買國巨
我告訴你喔我國巨這一段賺錢啦
有沒有
300到600多元這一段啦
這一段啦
賺錢啦
後面我就說開始小心了
跌的時候有沒有跌很快
我家要漲就漲 國際
我家要漲就漲 我家要跌就跌
我家要反彈 馬上反彈
我家要暫停就暫停
你告訴我喔 哪個老師人像只會這樣
我們說實在話
我不去4O話 我不去馬歐炮啊
我們是靠頭腦鍋的
所以投資廟
你要就是要我這樣分析師啊
我會救多少人的國際啊
我要不是我進場買
然後這樣可能姚慈欣母
可能同意的也看到我的
其他投信的也看到我的
不好意思低膽進場
你看能不能一直跳扣進跳扣嗎
不行啦
春天製作所好像也沒展20%
台灣就籌碼面問題嘛
所以我跟大家講喔
你記得一件事情我講得很清楚
我當初是不是講800元以上有賣壓
800元以下隨便談有沒有講有你這邊可以賺300元可以賺60%你可以賺300元是不是來看一下不用放大表心
在這邊攢一次800元
有賣壓
在這邊賺300元
有沒有
來喔
再看一下喔
這邊賺300元
在這邊
如果下去
再來一次再賺300元
你知道嗎
再賺300
因為
創新高很難啦
不要騙自己
再下去一次再賺300元
你三次300元
但是低點我來處理喔
我
教你怎麼樣
要到並出
你要找一個老師真的解決你的被動元件啊
你有被動元件來找我啊
投資廟
我跟你講跳舞不是專家
如果你覺得跳舞我很厲害
我告訴你
我連跳舞都很認真
股票我才專家啦
我才專家的專家 重心我也不是專家
雖然身材還算OK
那這不是我的專家
我真正專產什麼
我不要
我叫他長就長
我叫他結就長
你知道嗎
我告訴你
你到時候來個三次九百元
你什麼股票都解套了啦
郭駿解套 備客員就解套
你備客員就不找我 你找別人喔
那些人就是害你賠錢的
你不找我 你找誰
我跟你說認真的 你不找我 你找誰
今天反彈就有專家 你趕快找我 好不好
這個你要不要沒關係
已經很多人要了好不好
反彈殘殘99有沒有
真的殘殘99好不好
你不找我找誰好不好
這些股票都是一樣
我們這個都是一樣
我們剛才國際的傳播還沒播嘛對不對
國際那個1國際還沒播嘛對不對
還沒
還沒我們來播一下
那你看國際的傳播
再一次喔
我其實
我其實還是比較喜歡穿西裝啊
那個小行跟那個E
強烈要求我啊
那個
要脫掉西裝好不好
來我們看啊
我覺得很多股票都這樣
股票是這樣
國劇也殺過頭了
今天又再可以疊停辦
國劇有進場啦
不要再說我罵00981A啦
好不好
我現在跟00981A的那個搖齒金母
我搖齒金母之前有的人說我罵他
沒有
我支持你
我跟你講啊
我說甚至你現在可以買00981A
如果你不知道什麼時候要買
什麼時候要買
我做人很公道啦
我從來不拗人家
你打聽我郭忠為人
我做人很公道
我拗人家
不要之前說我一直叮
我跟你講如果是一個
大多位行情可以買什麼
主動是ETF
空頭行情那就不行了
所以你們現在了解吧
你看空頭行情它是不是跌很快
是
大家發現 喔原來姊姊真是說的是對的
原來怎麼樣
原來喔
主動型ETF以前是漲很兇
跌也跌很兇有沒有知道
這是主動型ETF有沒有
以前漲很兇有沒有
跌也跌很兇
所以只有大桌頭的時候可以買
你分不及什麼大桌頭什麼大空頭
就不要買了
有沒有知道
空頭的時候台灣50更沒什麼跌有沒有知道
有
前面這邊是輸人家啦
對不對沒錯吧
前面左邊輸人家啦
098年那時候很會漲
右邊是跌很少啦
贏人家很多有沒有
右邊有沒有
你家是不是跌很慘
可是你反彈的時候有沒有彈的比台灣56塊
有沒有看到
有
我都把特性告訴你
我說我不傲人家的
該念00981又念
該幫忙他
我就幫忙他
開心
國具喔
800元
我先講目前啦
我去800元
那個是一個
很漂亮的一個滿足價格
那會不會上1200
我且戰且走
我只說800元以下
基本上你很容易避著眼睛做多賺錢
那哲哲我知道啦
我明天做進場
我不管你
你兩根斬停板在進場
誰叫你不每天看我節目
不是看我跳舞才進來
不是看我買1005才進來
我告訴你啦 那都來不及了
是不是 你看到新聞報導
再看來不及
鐵粉是怎麼樣
所謂的鐵粉是這樣子
台灣股市
在沒有破4萬點的時候對不對
我是不是說破4萬點我就進場
沒錯吧
有沒錯
這邊我已經暗示了
隔天破4萬點
你就可以跟我一起進場了
你不相信
當我劍爆了
我節目上也講了
網路上討論我了
這跟十字K你也可以怎樣
在進場啊
禮拜四啊
沒錯
當天你還沒看我節目
你就知道我一定進場
因為你知道我信守承諾
隔天你不相信我
我已經確定了
我還可以看
我9A9J永峰版信的券3帳號
我沒有秀出帳號
因為不能秀
我要遵守主管機關跟我的約定
是
因為我太紅了 真的太紅了
我就不秀了
然後咧
可是我可以跟你去查券3有沒有信出
這知道吧
沒錯
你看那個加起來1130
然後永夢版新的那樣都會買
對不對
買0050
隔天你就可以跟我一起進場了
我也跟你發誓了
我說如果我有造假
永夢版新的來抓到我造假
我給他1億
你是永夢版新的
如果我說的話
你會幫我保留這幻化好不好
當然不會啊
當然不會 我可以賺1億耶
是不是我可以賺1億
為什麼不要
所以你看
我買1億台灣50馬上賺了
賺上去以後
是不是拉起來
唉
你每次都失落
可是拉起來以後你已經少了一個最好買點了
你少賺一千萬了
我一一就賺一千萬了
唉
所以我真的很好
我這一波整個完全
你所有話題也好
股票也好
ETF也好
我自己賺到錢也好
但我最想要是
我以為你們賺到錢
我愛你們
我在講一件事情
我大可偷偷買
我不要有壓力啊
你不要覺得整個在炫富啊
我不要跟大家講
為什麼
我是抱著風險啊
你知道如果破底了多少人會嚇我
100多萬粉絲 還有不認識我的
基本上沒有人不認識我好不好
他們會嚇我 知道嗎
就是你想想看你要講粉絲師
其實我是真的很想穿西裝
我有點害羞
來
所以這一波真的很準喔 來
這摺好帥 謝謝你們
我們今天給女粉男粉開心一點
來
我是慧元 今天環球金為什麼開高走低
因為
就是處置害的
3532台勝科
我看到
今天還在處置
今天是不是有新聞報導什麼
來
台勝科跌 那是不是會影響環球金
會
是不是 環球金禮拜五已經有一個暫停了嘛
是不是
是
那今天至少是暫嘛
你知道嗎 台勝科跌為什麼 因為處置啊
處置真的不好啦
我不知道是因為英雄所見略從
因為很多人在討論
然後還是
整個節目大家看了覺得去反應
有人去跟立委反應啦好不好
那我真的覺得說不過去
你說展要處置沒關係
讓大家冷靜一下
跌幹嘛要冷靜
你跌你不論大戶中十戶
你還要逼人家
去我現金買股票
還用現金買股票
然後先存到一定的專戶裡面
才能買股票
不是這樣搞吧
每個國家都是要增加流動性
只有我們台灣
這麼奇怪的特性
不能說台灣特有
我覺得這兩碼的事情
你時刻去問9個賞戶
都覺得這是不對的制度
晚上漲
我覺得晚上要處置我沒有意見
因為賞戶有時候會追
台股跟股市晚上跌
你不能用跌幅來處
把它已經跌幅還沒有量
不能
你看是不是我講了好像大家也反應了
我不知道是不是我啦
因為網路上也蠻多人討論的
我覺得有影響
可是我也不想去看這個話題
免得有影響
大家覺得我帶頭
我沒有 我們要做這個事情
可是我覺得
好的話題可以去討論 你懂得意思嗎
對的事情我們大家可以去做
好不好
來先跟大家講
你看喔
有沒有
股民哭喊
股票大跌到也賣不掉
立委完事件說
30年制度嚴重脫節有沒有看到
近期接貨大量股民陳情
是真的沒錯啊 流動性不行啊
你看哪有聯發科在可以處置的
華新科也是被處置的是不是
拜託
華新科也被處置是怎樣
是不是這不對啦是不是
你看一根這種
有水平線就知道他是被處置的
這不對你知道嗎
你看近期很多人在反應
我覺得這個是
這反應我覺得該反應要反應
讓大家不要激動
這是對的政策
那讓國主黨的機關在改變制度之前
一定會有時間
好不好
他們做的事情也很忙啊
是跟大家講
這個我讓大家都讓台灣更好沒什麼不好
他就說這我就不多說了
他就說他覺得分盤制度是過時
因為處罰他之前的
那現在是壟斷機制
是用現在盤中的好不好
檢討處置機制
我覺得重點是疊
不應該有流動性的限制啦
好不好
這是重點
我覺得其他的我不針對對跟錯
那講不完
到底是處置制度比較好
還是壟斷制度比較
問題是你不應該在股票跌的時候
還用它儲值
這才重點
你可以漲的時候都儲值
我沒意見
你要不要輪動我沒意見
跌的時候不應該
你知道那時候
哇還有漲停板反以前7%
金融海嘯的時候變成
一半就跌停板
什麼意思
3.5%就跌停板
你聽過嗎
就3.5%就漲停板
3.5%跌停板
金融海嘯的時候很慘
那就變成很多股票很容易跌停
你有看到台積電日月光都跌停嗎
沒有對不對
我看過
所以我跟你講我跌破4萬點
我根本沒有感覺
現在賺1000多萬我沒感覺
今天拉回1%啦
大概900萬吧
不然幫我算好不好
我自己算一下我算一下我賺多少錢
畫面那個
OK嗎
不要切喔
對戰檔喔不是對戰檔是
好像不能看這個
省意啊不重要那應該900萬好
我沒有在乎那個錢好不好
理論上我要5-6萬點
我再做好不好
那現在台子期
喔
台子期現在又跌了300點
怎麼看
我要說實在的話好不好
我不是今天看到盤後
台灣股市今天有點多展
可是台灣股市至少有確定一件事
上規指數至少有機會不要破底
你聽懂嗎
韓國股市
韓國股市這個底不能再破
記得我這個句話
一定要記得
來看一下
看一下
韓國股市
什麼底就是
他上禮拜五不是大漲嗎
就是那個
槓桿ETF
增加這個保證經過後開始反彈
前一個低點
不能跌破
記得計畫
韓國股市今天
漲15%
這韓國股市
漲15%對不對
這邊低點5262點
5262點不能跌破 記得我這句話
526不能跌破 今天大漲15%
然後再回檔個45%
很正常喔
OK嗎
知道我說什麼
看一下
很正常
從韓國股市最後跌5.13%
所以台灣股市今天算很強 因為台灣股市是紅的
所以明天跌我覺得很正常
因為韓國股市比想像中
台灣股市如果預期的強
可是韓國股市比我想像中弱
如果明天韓股市再跌
那會什麼啊
會一起拖累台灣股市
所以明天跌的機率比較高
你看我很恐怖喔
我說漲就漲
我說39000以下是買一點
就馬上漲停板
台灣股市漲停板
台積電漲停板
台灣50漲停板
我告訴你今天台灣50可能跌的機率比較高
今天是不是台灣50跌
是
很恐怖喔
可是今天台灣50跌最恐怖今天台灣50跌可是台股是漲的欸台股是漲的
漲NB66點有沒有看到
Ritchie我很恐怖
真的
我還知道台灣股市漲
可是台灣50可能跌
我都預告到前面
我還告訴你明天跌的距離有點大
那明天跌的距離越大
就算是要幹嘛
拉回做多
我並不認為會跌破10萬點的
所以你只要有跌你趕快進場
但是
我並不認為會跌破10萬點
你只要有跌
你就趕緊張
所以你看
為什麼你告訴我哪個老師現在可以秀出
恭喜
會員賺錢
只要被動元件的會員
偷偷賺錢
誰會秀出錢去
秀不出來啦
國際今天賺錢552啦
真的啦
哲哲沒跟你開玩笑秀不出來
我們沒有要批評人家我們講真的
運氣不錯啦
我真的運氣跟實力都缺一不可
都缺一不可
你越努力
我運氣越好
好不好
真的你去打聽一下
就你有沒有剛才跳舞
我真的跳到抽筋啊
你問他我剛才
沒錯
第一我剛才是不是跳到抽筋
我肚子在抽筋啊
真的運氣
胸部
你看我平常ok
這樣可ok
可是剛才那是在身體不要動
胸部要動
不是有胸肌就好了
那個很累
他都往後
真的很難
很難你知道嗎
好不好我們講
秀一下國劇的展停板
好不好
你看國劇那天跌停板
我們只能用這張圖不好意思
國際跌停板
很慘喔
你看喔
國際跌停板
結果你看
今天恭喜你幫我練一下畫面給你
好
8月3號星期一
恭喜2327國劇股價跳空噴出
開盤5分鐘就鎖上漲停
我們上週跌停勇敢進場
馬上就獲利大賺
我持續看好他
手上持股獲利續爆
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
你有上車嗎
有跟著投資長嗎
換名給我 來
有沒有跟著投資長
沒有跟著投資長差很多啊
真的
好不好
股票還是回到腦袋
腦袋才是最重要的
怎麼讓人家賺錢 彈桿
這是為什麼百萬粉絲
還不是從那個選股冠軍188%
從以前到現在沒有人一個人能接近我的紀錄啊
沒有辦法 一記188%欸
我告訴大家選10檔股票
10檔股票都暫停你猜看幾%
才10%而已
你們自己算一下好不好
才10%
對不對
你如果算不出來
你這個算不出來
你就啊才18
你有100%
那代表
數學還不夠好
我不是恰你
代表你更需要一個專人來幫你做股票
應該說給你當顧問
股票發展你身上比較安全
來
國際5分鐘所暫暫停
唉真的漂亮
真的漂亮
你去想想看
所以我告訴大家
這股票
阿哲哲
為什麼不買紅海
不是嘛
紅海之前沒什麼跌
所以沒什麼漲
可是有一檔股票
我可能考慮再買
年發科
因為年發科
最近說第二個客戶來了
所以真的有機會
TPU晶片
他有機會
至少
我不要說他2028年
我明年真的有機會大爆收
因為很多人就跟他生產
TPU晶片了
是
這個有暴震
那你就看一下
TPU晶片
然後AX的晶片
就這種專用的晶片以後會不會智原有機會
會不會智原有機會
注意一下以後智原會不會有機會
這是重點好不好
所以這個要注意一下
智原我是覺得連疊都不該疊
因為根本沒漲疊什麼東西
但他基本面他現在AI基本面還沒輪到他
A是一個晶片
或這種專用晶片現在台灣比較獨享的
應該說比較真的有收穫的是
連發科
那智原我賭的是
就有一點賭啦
有一點賭的成分
當然股票
至少你要知道賭的成分多少
我不會說完全重要資源
應該說我壓寶的是未來的爆發
你聽懂不是現在的
當然如果你要現在的爆發
很多股票還是可以現在的爆發
367是精彩
我們說這個本來要創新高股票跌有沒有
真的很扯
我說跌40%以上都可以買了對不對
對
你自己看一下
就差不多跌40%很扯對不對
你就連續兩個人展平板
之前
你有沒有發現到一件事情
國劇跟精彩都是一樣
每天跌停你不敢買
現在每天漲停你反問我要不要買
你們不覺得莫名其妙嗎
就像我的名言
創新高你也不敢買
直接講笑
跌30%你也不敢買
那你乾脆退出股市好了
創新高你也不敢追
跌30%你也不敢買
你退出股市
真的真的真的
今天到底怎麼樣
要不要買
人就很奇怪
跌的人也不敢買
現在暫停了反而
這只要不要買
只要買
我又不敢買
可是我好想買
你們就是這種感覺
我跟你講我這簡直是
AI 五眼佛界
來來這認真
你不要看我這禮拜
我做很多事情了
我要下載影片
下載影片你知道
C-Dance 2.5嗎
我們看一下
看這影片來
等一下
看一下 畫面先給我一下
先把它關一下
有沒有看到 這影片
他有 Seedance 2.0 跟 2.5 有沒有看到
下面是 2.0 上面是 2.5
他要 Seedance 2.0 來做
2.5 比較多分鏡喔
而且畫面比較連續喔
下面是 2.0 上面是最新版本的
都是中國大陸的
啊 AI 晶片還不夠喔
哇 還可以這麼厲害喔
如果 AI 晶片夠
以後我告訴你為什麼要真正演員的
所以我說以後要當演員的
真的且慢
除非你非常特色
你非常努力
不然我不建議
真的我不建議
我不建議就是
至少你要
有時候不建議啊
風險比較高啦
好不好
這樣好像
我不想要唱人家的夢想
來
怎樣
再一次再一次
畫面換
你看 上這個也出了
你看 嗚嗚嗚
那個人出了 聞到
嗨
你看看
你不覺得上面的畫面更大嗎
更清楚嗎
它分鏡更突如的咧
嘴巴張開會聞到
把手走出來
然後你看那女生
記憶口的表情緒更誇張
上面的你知道嗎
那下面的直接拿那個
下面的噴小白布的那個
臉比較強你知道嗎
這個臉比較真
你知道嗎
有
就結束了
好 這是不錯
上面是2.5C dance
很多人是不是喜歡看
中國的言情的小說
如果中國的那個穿越劇
或中國的古裝劇
有沒有看一下
每次這樣子
要不然就霸氣總裁
要不然就
這個女生可能逃出公外啊
人家逃出公外要跌倒怎麼辦
你看一下
一個人是救她
你是誰啊
快幫我下來
畫面跟聲音都接著
我就是你翻牆牙套
你是什麼
真的假人
當你分不出來真的假人的時候
你就會看AI劇了
不用了啦
老人家現在都不在乎啦
老人家我媽怎麼講
我媽就像我說的
她說沒有我早就看AI劇了
我媽怎麼講
真強者
真什麼然後假強者
你知道之前
你知道嗎
真強者假廢物
這個你去那個
YouTube找一下
真強者假
真的很強的人
真強者假廢物
那根本看不出來
我一看出來是AI
連配角那麼帥我不相信
連配角也那麼美我不相信
連配角主角配角都漂亮帥了
所以跟你講這AI
這個AI是其中一種運用
像你知道還有一個是呀
沒有錯
像好像已經有好幾種
好像是最新的OpenAI
ChairGPG的
下一版本已經
破解了
我之前不是這個87年的數學猜想嗎
破解了好多數學猜想啊
之前只有破一個而已啊
好多數學猜想下一代啊
都瞬間破解
全部解出來了
所以我告訴大家
其實癌症也是一樣
你這些蛋白質的成分
你怎麼去破解它
怎麼適合它
它就這樣子
以前蛋白質
蛋白質那
哇
這種基因鑰匙
你要從裡面幾萬把裡面
你要瞞錯
你要一百把事
像不必
你的AI
會跑程式告訴你模擬這個環境
哪一個
藥物是最
最容易解決這個癌症
有些癌症是麻煩的喔
就算肺癌都有好幾種
七八種十幾種的肺癌
腫瘤有好幾十種
雖然肺癌腫瘤有好幾十種
還會突變
還會逃逸
怎麼辦
所以這個時候可能要靠藥物
所以怎麼辦
所以我問你一件事
今天我聽到沈玉玲
之前我們公司磨我的尾牙
要找過他
他說一年的藥錢20萬
他說20萬所以要拼命工作
那問你一件事
那20萬他要不要付
得付啊
要
沒辦法啊
至少學來有救啊
以前學來根本就沒什麼救啊
那20萬
不要說20萬
30萬 40萬他也會付啊
是不是
這就是沒辦法
如果是我
萬一啦
我媽可能不喜歡甜言之外
我任何人發生這種事
他還是得付
那或者說一般人
不要說付啦
我沒有
我不要說得病
我想不想延年益壽
長壽啊
我多個10歲就好啦
要我花
叫做
你問我是1億買台灣50
比較
比較10字
还是一亿增加10年的寿命
但是增加10年的寿命
对
没有
但是增加10年的寿命啊
是不是
所以我也愿意投资啊
很多人愿意投资啊
你懂意思吗
所以你不是说
AI 哎呀看自由现金流量
我看什么东西
我不是说那是个很好笑的事情吗
我不是跟2008年一样
就算什么营业现金流量为负
笑死人
结果现在亚马逊反而斩了
对亚马逊反而斩了
自由现金流量为负又不在乎了
我说这个乱七八糟
你们多去观察AI
我告诉你我看的是
我看的是遠凡
你不要給我看我地下有什麼東西
有沒有蟑螂老鼠我不在乎啦
所以這些股票通通到時候都會漲
我跟你講你不要到時候5萬點
我跟你講明天有拉回你要用你做多
現在有拉回你要用你做多好不好
真的用你做多好不好
那講話同時又跌幅又熟練了
你有沒有覺得哲哲對你們很好
真的對你們很好啦
沒有像哲哲這樣的人啦
今天我們直播人數哦
有點爆掉哦
就是爆不是爆就是有點那個
反應有點有點辣哦
7000多人算不錯了哦
來
這折帶貼圖是你們出的
是我們出的
今天走歐巴瘋
謝謝大家
來我們來看一下另外一個簡訊
精彩
來幫忙唸
好
8月3號星期一
恭喜3374精彩股價跳空噴出
開盤才7分鐘就漲停鎖死
我們買進到現在最高
已經大賺56%
我持續看好它
手上之骨獲利續報
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
真的賺大錢你不覺得嗎
是
我精彩真的很敢報喔
我之前報到100%我沒走
後來掉下去了
你不是可以跟我會員
比較一樣降低成本嗎
那會員
我沒記錯有買的會員都賺錢
所以我跟你講
我真的不是有時候不是要賺
560%你不要找我國手好不好
我環球金賺100%我都沒走了
我跟你說這環環境真的有機會2000元
我認為啦 不是說一定啦 我們這邊有
我們主管機關有規定我們 但是我們本來股市就沒有一定
所以我問大家一件事情 如果賺這些錢
你賺到怎麼辦
我說你賺到沒關係 你會開心 你賺不到怎麼辦
你明明看到 我問大家一件事 如果再一次4萬點
你真的會跟我一起進產嗎
我覺得立立會 一一一會啦 你們會不會
你們可能還是不會 你們嘴巴說會 你們還是不會
再一次恐怕還是不會
或者買一點點
我只問你一件事
現在如果台灣股市會就會到5萬點到6萬點
明年到6萬點
我認為有機會至少6萬點請問你現在到底是4萬點買還是4萬3買有差嗎沒差重點是4萬點不一定回得到啊當然沒有差
重點是後面能不能漲嘛
只要有賺錢就好了嘛
你知道我能力就該買就買
精彩這邊賺5.99%
他很多股票要漲了啦
真的啦好不好
唉
如果股票真的要漲
納科今天也拉起來了
納科的問題是
怎麼樣
跌太少
好不好
所以我說你看群聯
有沒有
群聯今天有沒有看到
也是怎麼樣
829群聯也快要漲停
群聯我覺得比較有看頭啦
因為群聯實在跌太深你知道嗎
OK嗎
這比較多大戶在藍雅科
那沒有關係
我納科也賺了快300%
前兩次好像是
加起來是
加起來204再一次61
如果再負利的話應該是接近300%
這個實在績效 你自己看一下
這不能造假
我們秀的是普通位元
我不要秀那種
秀那種你看不到的
特別位元啊
特別位元當然是特別的愛給特別的你
來
年8顆我們賺了130幾%
因為出兩次啊 好不好
國劇賺了快100%
南亞顆賺61%
NO NO NO
南亞顆去年初的時候
好像是去年到年初
兩次賺了204%
是
南亞顆
我進場就是賺錢
國劇我也兩進兩出
我打算七進七出
要不要幫你做價差
所以你有國劇
你有被動元件
你有信倉店
和聲譚
華興科
這些XXX的被動元件
一大堆被動元件族群
你要找我
因為現在被動元件
目前為止
我的績效
勝率是百分之百
沒有錯吧
沒錯
我都進場
都賺錢啊
是
一堆人在國劇
怎麼樣 犧牲慘烈
我在國際上面笑呵呵
很難算新高
就是因為很難算新高
所以
可能只有我能幫你解套
你不找我你會後悔
有國際的
有記憶體的
你不找我你會後悔
你被套牢了你不找我你會後悔
你現在被套牢了你換股
現在談兩根斬停板
很多人會要談兩根斬停板
如果你沒有你股票
跌那麼實在沒談兩根斬停板
至少談一根板
不然你真的很危險問題很大
你還不來找我
你知道我厲害你還不來找我
你要找害你跌的人嗎
你要找讓你買高點的人嗎
問題可大啦
你不要二者之後我就不管了
我跌三者的話不管了
錯!我就說可以做價差
你自己扪心自問
你覺得國際人創新高的基多少
短期內高不高
你告訴我
這麼多哀鴻騙眼
你覺得那些人傻瓜
我股成本900塊我通通賣給你
你要買哪個大戶那麼傻啊
直接拉起來拉起來拉起來
有可能嗎
這邊套好賣藥都不用你他媽
800元以上的
800元以上套好賣藥都不用你他媽
不可能嗎怎麼可以一下子彈到這陣子
這個技術分析不是這樣學的啦
你當然這邊傻瓜
我只要問你一件事假設你有幸
1100元
你套1100元
我跟你講你只要解套一般人解套就想走了啦
所以1100會有賣壓
那你覺得1000元不會有賣壓
900元不會有賣壓
一堆人等你幫他拉起來解套
所以不會有人想幫你拉
只有我幫你做價差
不會有人想幫你拉
你趕快來找我好不好
不論你要取名是反彈99還是價差99
你有這些股票有記憶體的被動人籍
你趕快找我
因為只有我敢在最低點的時候買台灣護士
你有沒有覺得我今天反彈的信息比較好
为什么
我根本不在乎台湾公司
迟早
我认为迟早会赚钱
我认为
可是我最在乎的是会员
所以我今天很多会员谈起来
我很开心知道吗
那个小杨像几分
4E
LINE的贴族是我们出来
对我们刚才讲
以后 IG 就对
看 IG 跟 TRAIN
因为 TRAIN 一开始是从 IG 转过来的
所以 IG 跟 TRAIN 是同一个账号
S178 178
你们知道吗
OK吗
S178 178
有什么 S178 那假的
好不好
LINE 是小二手 S178
你這邊看為主
以臉什麼
臉書的不要理他
臉書很多假帳號
IG也很多假帳號
TRAID也很多假帳號
臉書就是這樣子
就是犯了很多詐騙期間的混型
YouTube不一樣
我們跟Google的關係很好
我們公司跟Google的關係很好
一直有假冒的
我之前怎麼樣
我馬上把他抓下來
影片就可以直接檢舉他了
所以我們記得一件事情
以影片為主
影片講的這幾個帳號為主
其他的通通假的
你不知道你打的電話來電
來電恰奇 0806 8085
記者拜託不要打這個了
不要打這個了
算是有民視啊東升啊什麼
去EDN4找我
TVS記者可不可以以後不要把我拍那麼醜
民視都把我拍很帥
可以不要把我拍那麼醜
我講實在話
把我拍得好慘白喔
所以我化妝也不要這樣子
民視
東升都給我拍蠻帥的
OK
好啦
大家看
這開玩笑的
開玩笑的
別再控單了
不要看公团单
真的不要看公团单
这则世界明天好像有法会
法说会
法说会吗
我查一下
自然帮我查一下明天有没有
好不好
世界金也该涨
我看世界金涨
环球金更该涨
世界金都缺货
环球金也会缺货
世界金要跟环球金拿细金
你觉得记忆体不用拿
也要拿
你不知道这是
我常跟你讲你要知道这是
OK吗
来现在几分呢
43了 6196凡宣也是一樣
你們自己看一下
6196凡宣
強烈宣的問題是跌太少
我現在對跌太少股票沒興趣
他很快就創新高了
可是我現在是要新位元新朋友們讓他賺錢
好不好
就是讓他買低股票
微星也沒什麼好講的
微星的問題就是沒有跌
所以他現在沒什麼漲
微星很快就創新高了好不好
你們想要那種追強制股的
強制動能股的
就追強的
那我跟你講
微信就是你現在最想要的股票
好不好
再來就是
凡宣就沒什麼動啦
精彩也有機會
記得我說這些東西好不好
我不去四歐瓦
我不去馬好跑
該講就講了喔
所以你看喔
台灣股市我說今天會翻紅
哪個老師敢講
你告訴我哪個老師敢講嘛
禮拜六誰加班
加班人真的不多了啦
大部分都是我們摩訪的分析師
加班以後告訴你今天有機會漲
你告訴我誰
上禮拜四
在崩盤的時候
我說拜託你們
再給這
我知道很多人你們又會愛我
只要跟著我
再給指責最後一次
愛我的機會
愛指責的機會
我是不是講得很清楚
是
你們不理我啊
我也說過了
另一條
衝就對了
怕什麼
不論漲創新高你也不敢追
拉回三次不追你也不敢買
你真的當我財經綜藝節目喔
你拜託一下
不要再給我結這一段喔
不要當財經綜藝節目
真的我是
我講這件就跳舞一樣
我是伯駿一下
可是要讓你記得我中心核心點是什麼
股市中央景要創新高
你要用立買啊各位
用立買啊
我是真的很激動耶你知道
去香港你要怎樣分析師好不好
我不去吃的話我也不去買後泡啦
哪有跌破的時候公開買一億的壓力那麼大
是不是
他要去湊錢
還要公開買我私底下買也可以啊
每個人幫我數到今天賺錢還賠錢
我是為了你們要給你們信心
馬上展停板你告訴我哪有展停板
去年
所持展停板好像好幾年沒有了
這很誇張這比重的這應該跟
熱透整齊的
跟大熱透的機率更低啦
就是熱透等級的啦
是不是
你今天剛才要講到分析室
買了以後閃停板
然後今天很多人說會跌
我說會拉紅
我說會拉起來
明天跌的機率比較高
所以你不要看這跌沒關係
重點是
上跪指數來看一下
上跪指數
破底機率比較低了
所以如果明天真的有拉回
如果你想想看
你要買國具還是買環球金
還是買中衛金
你不知道你趕快來一槍行
08068085好不好
反彈99妝案
好不好隨時會結束
我頂多禮拜二禮拜三就要結束了
好不好
這跟大家講
我們之後看一下大家有沒有什麼反應
好不好
日傳千萬難能
全人者者一在突破
謝謝大家
者者加油我愛者者我也愛你們
好不好
OK嗎
笑到肚子痛謝謝大家
就是要截取這一段
來來財經中節目
越兇越喜歡
很多人就喜歡敲桌子
莫名其妙
桌子到現在這個是什麼牌的
我們到時候要介紹一下
來來
笑死了
山東市根本沒有人買啦
夜盤怎麼看
衝衝衝
我都聽不到沒關係
志永剛好說了
志永我覺得
害你漏尿
我這樣子已經漏尿了
那不是我的問題
是你問題比較大好不好
來
OK
好啦這個不要看空單
空單不准很久了啦好不好
不准很久了啦
今天空單口住多少
沒關係 不准很久了好不好
來來
姐姐襯衫是訂製的嗎
有些襯衫是訂製的
有些這一件
你知道嗎不好意思喔
身材太好的
其實不需要怎麼訂製襯衫跟西裝
都有訂製的也有買的
這件不用的
好 因為姐姐
身材本來就不錯了
所以不需要訂製
好 這件不是訂製的 謝謝
可是也不便宜啦
不是不是
不好意思
身材好可以不用
再臭屁啦
我不喜歡一直炫耀
來
來喔
技嘉之後看
什麼零零什麼的
我組裝型ETF我沒興趣啦
九成到最後會輸台灣50啦
只是
反彈的時候或強勢上場的時候
可以
可以買一下啦
那你不如買股票
你看國際有兩根斬定板
哪個被動型
哪個組裝型ETF有兩根斬定板
對不對沒錯吧
沒錯
是啊
技嘉怎麼看
技嘉也沒什麼跌
技嘉已經算沒什麼跌
你不要想太多啦好不好
技嘉沒展沒跌
技嘉太老了啦
真是老AI
這不動 我也想換
我會上去
他上去又再考慮換
我會看你一陣子
看你一陣子
因為他真的
他蠻看跌的你懂嗎
技嘉蠻看跌的
可是再上去他再不動
我們找一種動能比較強大的
比較容易創新高好不好
去想想看
你要找什麼意思
我也愛你們啦好不好
我也愛你們
農資好不好
台股真的震很兇
找一個真的會懂
跳震凶舞的分析師
我真的懂政典的時候
該怎麼幫你
好不好
所以最後我們要結束幾分了
49分來啦
我們最後反彈49分剛好結束啦
不要超過50分了
反彈99專案
隨時截止好不好
你去想看聊天室好不好
歡迎來一條請
0800668885或加爾赖私訊我
不論對我錯誠誠一切一切
預告在前面
哇今天台灣股市真的反彈了
哇我們一堆股票展停板
國具展平板
中美金今天也展平板
沒時間講
中美金我也能看好
黃金金看好
我當然看好中美金
精彩也展平板
這麼多股票展平板
你還不加入者子的行業
趕快來價錢 0806 8085
或是交給你私信我
說這招 會不會怎麼賺
這招 我要賺大錢
我捷徑我所能來幫你賺大錢
謝謝各位
我愛你們 掰掰
本节目资料仅供参考
投资人应独立判断
只剩批评估并自负投资风险